[Music]
if you visit california
you might be inclined to go to
disneyland or jump in your convertible
and take highway 1 up the coast
or maybe make a pilgrimage to yosemite
all very fine choices but if you're the
kind of person who revels in our
planet's extremes
then it's route 395 that you're after
[Music]
this one glorious road will carry you
from death valley's
desert floor to sky high views of mount
whitney
you can see the 5 000 year old
bristlecone pines
the oldest living organisms
or the bizarre tufa towers of mono lake
and true to california's boom and bust
spirit
you can saunter around the ghost town of
bodhi
what a novel experience to find an empty
american city
where all the businesses are shut down
to do 395 upright it helps to have a
guide
and mine is a man named jan and his crew
aaron what's that tidy
the hardest partying dog of all time
jan agreed to show me some of what 395
has to offer
but only if we agreed not to disclose
any locations
[Music]
my name is jan surostra i'm an
industrial designer out of la
and i spent a lot of time camping and a
lot of time in the eastern sierra
it's a place i love and sometimes i'm
known
as 395 north because instagram this yep
my instagram account
and i don't like to be known as that but
i'm trying to use it
to set a good example and do more with
it than just social media
[Music]
where did we end up camping we got here
lately i wasn't even
sure where we are this is uh blm land
right on the outskirts of national
forest
and uh it's one of my favorite places in
the world basically
everything outdoors wrapped into one yep
yeah good thing about california man oh
man we have so much national forest and
public land
yeah that you can literally just cruise
out
and find a place to camp it's ours
what i wish was mine is yon's sweet
truck
it's a 2019 ford ranger has about
200 watts of solar in it and a fridge
and has everything that an rv has except
for a toilet yeah but just
on a smaller simple scale you drive us
around
day to day in la yep and then just roll
out when you want it's my daily driver
um handle's great um and then when i'm
done with work i can just
bail and go camping so the camper
basically
has only what i need think of it as
backpacking with a car yep
the fridge has a couple compartments
this is just a kitchen box stove
utensils and a bunch of stuff
this one has just dry food then when you
get inside there's a bed
the bed flips up so you've got tons of
room in here
this awning
is phenomenal
if you want to pull that over
that's cool let me just pop that up
sorted so home on wheels yeah this is my
vacation house it was so nice man
even with his nomad lifestyle yan faces
the same big question as the rest of us
do the internet and smartphones have to
ruin everything
when you find the super special
beautiful spots is that
you busting out a map and like looking
where it might be cool to go or is it
word of mouth and just getting to know
people all the locals and
if i see a dirt road i just want to go
down so
a lot of it's just aimless rambling it's
a desire to just see something
check that out for some reason it's more
fulfilling
than getting a recommendation from
somebody or
there's tons of apps and websites now
road trip apps camping apps
they've proliferated the knowledge is
accessible on the internet right
i used to fight the geo tags
and and i would get really pissed off
like why are you posting this place it's
going to blow up it's going to get
trashed
now i've realized that you you can't
fight it the internet has just shrunk
the world
so we're not going to stop it we're not
going to stop people from
going there so i'm a lot more focused
in conversation now with trying to set a
good example
when you go pick up your trash when
you're
pooping out in the wilderness don't
leave your toilet paper on the top
you know make sure you follow you know
good steps for leaving no trace
as a thank you for this quick guide to
pooping etiquette
we made yon heron and lemmy some tacos
and we all took in the night sky and
knocked back a couple of drinks
take that apocalypse
the thing about good times and serenity
in 2020
is that they're fleeting at best after
we split up from yawn and continued on
our way
smoke started to envelop us
[Music]
the plus side was that our rv no longer
smelled like feet
the downside was breathing
a man david here suggested that we try
and outflank the smoke by cutting
through yosemite
without a reservation we had to talk our
way in uh yes no stopping no getting out
and
in the valley yeah nope no problem we
just yeah we just wanted to get through
it was a beautiful choice glad we got
out of the smoke
whoa whoa okay but not quite as
effective as we had hoped
fast forward for hours or so and we had
managed to trade the smoky majesty of
yosemite
for the smoky look at it
strip malls of the central valley
we have made it sort of out of the smoke
all the way
across yosemite national park and here
to the gorgeous central valley of
california
we're off to see a kind of surprising
tech startup
that is making some pretty strange
machines
to serve all the growers out in this
region
[Music]
and where would you we're here in this
near fresno this is
california farm country right we're just
south of fresno a town called kingsburg
so we're right in the central valley of
california
very very large farming valley here
it's kind of considered the bread basket
of of the world
the central valley stretches out over
about 20 000 square miles
and the farmers here produce about
one-fourth of the food that americans
eat
including a whole lot of fruits and nuts
tell me a little bit of the background
of gus i know some of this is like a
family business the the roots of this go
back
a ways tell me kind of like how we we
got to what's essentially like a startup
i guess
yeah definitely so the founder of our
company is dave krinklaw
and he started the business back in
1982.
he started with is basically with his
dad
was commercial spraying of trees and
vineyards
got to the point where our biggest
challenge was labor
just the shortage of it really he was
forced into innovating
and he had had this idea for quite some
time about doing a
driverless sprayer and it
finally got to the point where he said
you know what i either got to get out of
this business
or i'm going to innovate organic or not
crops need to be sprayed
and this process has to take place a few
times a year
this means hiring a lot of people to
work long hours under serious pressure
and so just like the tech bros to the
north
gus decided to solve all of its problems
with robots
on this like labor point you guys have
set this up where you can have somebody
in a truck and and that one person can
monitor i think like eight of these
in order to operate gus you have one guy
or girl that sits in a pickup
and they monitor from a laptop computer
so
that person is basically just watching
all the vehicles
on the screen they can monitor up to
eight of them at a time
while they're out there spraying in the
orchard and so
that user interface really provides them
with all the information they need to
make sure that the machines are safe
and that they're doing the correct job
so it tells them what speed they're
driving
the engine rpm the amount of gallonage
per acre that they're applying
at any given time so if any one of the
machines has an issue
it's going to send an alert to that
laptop much like a self-driving car
these beasts use gps lidar and cameras
to see
and navigate the world around them they
also rely on pre-built maps of the
orchards for extra guidance
gus builds the machines right here
and then takes them out for robot
training on this orchard next door
it's here that the company learns if the
machines will behave
and do as their software and human
masters command
so this so this is kind of like that
this is a test
orchard where you guys put it through
the paces and work on the
technology yeah so this is our our test
orchard right here it's right by our
building as you can see in the
background
so every new machine as it comes off the
assembly line
it's put through a commissioning test
right here we test all the sensors on
the machine
autonomous computer all the safety
systems make sure it's doing what it's
doing
prior to when it's delivered to a
customer
so what's it doing now so right now he's
doing a test spray
so he's just turning the water on to
make sure that the system comes up to
pressure
spraying water out of the nozzles just
to make sure it's all functioning
properly okay
it's got like a crazy turbine at the
back yeah so it's basically just a big
fan
okay and that fan is driven off of the
cummins diesel motor
and it just basically creates a big
airflow
gus is already selling these vehicles to
brave modern farmers
and people the world over have taken
notice of its machines
and if you just sold them in the central
valley or like throughout the us or even
overseas or where
like where are they going yeah so right
now the majority of our
machines are here in california in the
central valley
however we do have machines and
customers in
florida and the citrus industry over
there as well as australia and i think
you started selling them in like
december of 2019
yeah so we started taking orders early
last year
for the sprayers and the first
deliveries we made were in december of
2019.
okay and they how much do they cost each
um so
our our retail price on these machines
is 285 thousand dollars so it's like
it's not a small
investment but i'm sure the regular
sprayers aren't aren't
yeah i mean we're honestly not too far
away from conventional equipment on our
price
and the main thing is is that the return
on investment is very
very quick due to all the labor savings
and the increased efficiency i mean
these machines
they just they just drive but basically
what we're doing
besides this machine this is our our
first machine we call it orchard gus
mainly designed for your your nut trees
as well as citrus and fruit in the
future
we're working on a few other projects
we're going to do
more machines one of them is actually a
vineyard sprayer so
vineyards are much tighter spacing so
the machine has to be physically smaller
and then we've got our eyes on doing a
lot of other innovating
that right there friends is a central
valley farmer putting his whole
fruit basket on the table gary's ted
talk can't be far off
and with that it was time to get back in
the rv
and to confront what happens when three
men
are bested by their own failings
and the forces of entropy
[Music]
next on hello world we cruise into the
mojave desert
in search of a lunar lander we have
instruments
that we are going to deliver to the
south pole of the moon in december
2022. instruments that are trying to
scan
the surface of the moon and hang with a
test pilot
who walked away from this
so we just finished part two of a
three-part series of
ashley and the team hello world's big
trip down highway 395.
now we seem to have gotten a little
farther south right we're like kind of
in
well we're in undisclosed locations
through sort of the the eastern sierras
and then
and then a little bit farther in the
central valley but so first i want to i
want to ask you how you found
jan like there seems to be this tension
where he like
you know he he feels like this man with
conflicts like he wants to put all this
beautiful footage out and
so wonderful to look at and yet there
seems to be this sense of tension of
like oh is he contributing to
a kind of way of consuming the world
that he doesn't really believe in
yeah well that's true and then john he
was like awesome
to hang out with and his whole crew they
were really fun to hang out with but he
was he was actually hard
to get a hold of we found him the my
awesome producers
on the show found him and and reached
out and then you know part of it was
like we
i think we were like trying to contact
him for like a month and it was very
spotty because he would just he would
just be like gone for two weeks
and have no connection and not really
get back and then i think there were a
couple emails where he's like i want to
do it but i kind of don't want to do
it um i think once we hung out we got
along so well
and i think he could he'd watch some of
the shows and he was
i think he knew we weren't trying to
like you know do some uh
gotcha we're gonna expose all your
secret spots to everybody
and so so it ended up being okay um what
was the pool you were in
like hot pool or cold pool yeah i hope
my describe is right and yawn doesn't
get mad at me
i mean it was just out on some uh
some land where they they kind of like
spike you know down into the ground and
and create
create this pool it wasn't super hot it
wasn't cold either it was kind of nice
yeah it was refreshing i remember that
day it was really really hot and
we'd been stuck in the rv all day it was
good to get out and sort of
feel clean for once yeah and i
blm land is this really special
type of land that's i mean it's in
california and obviously across
across the us as well but that's you
know like burning man happens on blm
land like there's
i think you get a better sense of how
much of a big
part of california is sort of like
uninhabited
run you know sort of maintained by the
government but there's there's we can
just go
and see yeah yeah yeah we get into that
a little bit
uh there in chatting with yanni he was
talking about the difference
you know off camera he was talking about
going to texas and some other states and
just
how much harder it was to find spots
like that and
and people aren't always as excited to
see you like romping around
um in some of these places and so yeah
california's got a magic
like that i mean and again i sort of you
know
even though i live here it was a
reminder that i don't take advantage of
this stuff as much
as i should so it was good it was nice
to have like somebody who really knew
what they were doing and to remind you
that um you just need to think more
creatively
yeah and then you went to yeah another
big aspect of california's
vast land being rows and rows and rows
and rows of orchards
nuts fruits which is the kind of stuff
you drive past when you're going to
yosemite and stuff like that
um where how did you find the how did
you find these
robot spray orchard robot sprayers
yeah this was a cool one i mean this is
one where like somebody reached out to
me
either on twitter or instagram and
they're like you got to see this thing
and these these guys down in the central
valley they're selling
yeah these like all those silicon valley
guys talking about their self-driving
cars they don't even sell them these
guys are like selling these things they
can't even make them
fast enough and and i kind of ignored it
the first couple times this guy was
persistent he didn't even work at gus he
just he was like lives out there
and then finally you know i pulled up
the picture i'm like oh yeah i gotta go
see this thing and then
their website like it kind of blew me
away too i don't want to
seem like um i'm trying to like
downplay the the technology of the
central valley and stuff but their their
site was pretty amazing and it had these
likes
you know the super um
impressive videos of the stuff in action
and so once i saw that it actually
seemed
real i was like oh yeah i want to go go
see these guys
they were kind of nonchalant about how
they'd like put it together which i
thought was impressive and like
so different to the valley as you know
where like everyone's telling you how
awesome they are
all the time and and um and these guys
were just like yeah we just picked up
some lidar and like we had a couple guys
like
write the software for this and we got
some help from this company
yeah they're like next thing you know
the sprayer's driving itself i was like
okay
how much of a difference is it i know
you mentioned that they they also use
pre
sort of pre-drawn out maps of the
orchard which i have to imagine is
pretty helpful you're also not dealing
with like cross traffic
like i mean yeah yeah like
bicycles in the orchard right but no for
sure the difficulty of like
getting a self-driving car to work is is
much
much harder but um and they do yes
the the pre-drawn maps is totally
helpful i mean you can get all these
like satellite images now or or
aerial footage and so and then with gps
i mean you're telling
this thing exactly where it needs to go
and then a lot of the
the lidars and the cameras on the thing
i think it mostly just in case something
runs into it or something like a tree's
fallen down since the
the pictures were taken and so a lot of
it's for safety
um but i still thought it was still
surprising to me because i've done this
for a long time and you just don't have
i've never really had a startup from the
central valley reach out to me
at all you know and then i have been i
got into like ag tech
for a while and i noticed that um
people were doing cool stuff but they
did kind of like tend to keep it to
themselves it was like this
cup this farm would make all this sort
of custom machine but not really
sell it and so um that kind of caught my
attention that these guys had shipped
them all the way to places like
australia
already yeah that's pretty cool yeah ag
tech is
um it's pretty wild like i i know
someone who runs a
dairy farm and they milk the cows using
a robot that uses lasers to locate
the utter the cow walks in and then
there's like some lasers and then it
just automatically builds it it's just
incredible yeah the computer vision
stuff's getting weird so i know this
other company in idaho and they're using
computer vision so like picking rock
is like a big thing on farms i always
pictured in my head that
you got out in the field and you pull
off the rocks once and that's sort of it
but they get churned up by the ground
all the time and so this is like this
annual
exercise where like humans have to go
out and
scour the field and carry all this heavy
stuff and so you know this other company
is using computer vision and robot hands
to
to go do that so i guess uh you know
i'm sure over the next 10 20 years it's
going to get pretty pretty weird
out on the farm
you